Mario Batali accused of sexual
misconduct by multiple women
[Music]
the celebrity chef is stepping back from
his restaurant Empire as well as his
hosting gig on ABC's the chew amid
allegations of sexual misconduct in a
story published to eat her on Monday
four women came forward with personal
stories accusing the 57 year olds of
quote inappropriate touching in a
pattern of behavior that spans at least
two decades in October Batali was
reported by an employee for alleged
inappropriate behavior a spokesperson
for the chef's hospitality group told
eater this incident was the first formal
complaint against Batali who was
required to undergo training although he
remains an owner of his restaurants
Batali announced that he will take a
leave of absence and apologized in a
statement to ET I take full
responsibility and am deeply sorry for
any pain humiliation or discomfort I
have caused to my peers employees
customers friends and family
a spokesperson for ABC said in a
statement te t quote we have asked Mario
Batali to step away from the chew while
we review the allegations that have just
recently come to our attention
[Music]
you
[Music]